so how is Flair did you behave at all
dude the guy I'm gonna just go out on a
limb and say the guy's got some issues
you think yeah
I mean he just he'd drink his own blood
if it you told him in a gin in it I
think yeah 30 years I never saw him take
a drink of water yeah brother breakfast
hard liquor vitamins hard liquor yeah
lunch a couple beers hard to look at
night wine I love him to death oh yeah
but I never saw him drink drink any
water until recently I think he's back
off the water back on the roll again
yeah he said he's back here he said he
did 30 days sober and then walked across
the street to a bar and turned in his
chip yeah that's right the funny part is
he can he just can he's that's who he is
that's the man the funny part is when he
was had that
really serious health issue yeah
um I got a call from Wendy and it didn't
look good so I flew up we got a plane
right away flew up to Atlanta
and uh
I walked in the doctor pulled me sorry I
was saying your buddy here
has destroyed his body the inside of
some of his intestines and stuff were
dying and stuff because he's got a five
percent chance
I'm making it through the surgery
so he goes in
we wait Jimmy Hart was with me who
waited we waited but he comes out he's
still alive
um his girl is crying his daughter
Ashley's crying I'm sitting there
holding his hand holding Zan
five percent chance to make it he opens
his eyes he looks up after he goes Hogan
get me a six-pack I wonder what first
thing he said to me get me a six-pack
when he woke up
yeah I'm not shocked man oh no I was
just tripping man just kind of blew my
mind you know yeah he's a good guy bro
he's one he's the best there ever was
he's uh well he and he says that about
you you know no he's the best there ever
was is he the better wrestler is he the
better and is he the Best Entertainer is
he the best wrestler he was more
consistent because I quit and I really
didn't care about the business I came
from playing in a rock and roll band
yeah and that whole attitude
but once he got in it he was you know he
was real consistent and he held it down
like when I was doing the New York
Madison Square Garden thing he held a
southern belt thing down which was
actually a little harder because he was
going an hour every night sometimes
they'd do like what they call it
Broadways where nobody wins you do like
two hour Broadways with Harley Race just
just those two in the ring yeah because
they didn't want to switch the belt so
they didn't want to make either wrestler
that's okay you're going out Broadway
tonight wow so somebody told me to go
now Broadway I should just beat me I'm
out of here I'm going to get room
service and a beer you know yeah yeah no
I say he was the best serverless simply
because he was so consistent now I was
talking about who drew the most money
or internationally who saturated all the
international markets over the years you
know I had more time and I had more seat
time like a good race car driver I had
more seat time in all these foreign
markets and Rick spent the majority of
his career down south and he didn't have
that swing arm to plug in the Mozambique
zambali Malaysia all these places where
people will know who Hulk Hogan is but
they might not know who Tom Brady is
right
but you know he uh he was the man I love
working with him yeah
yeah he he um he's a scrappy he just
will not be denied really you know
there's something about him and there
was something about that whole NWA
um I don't know if it was AWA or NWA at
that time when he was really the king of
it you know but it came one I think on
Sunday night like it was almost like I
had friends that watched wrestling right
they knew you but I knew if they really
watched wrestling if they knew about
um if they knew about NWA you know
that's when you could tell if they were
the next level of [__] you know it
was a lot of guys that just couldn't
even read and they'd be in the stands
yelling the signs misspelled yeah you
got me dialed in to be like that whole
Crockett Southern belt promotion you had
to be a wrestling fan oh you'd have
rabies I feel like I was more accessible
to the housewives and the kids that
didn't know what wrestling was yeah you
know so it was a whole different thing
but then Rick came our way yeah and I'd
been begging him to come up there for
years he wouldn't leave
and then uh once he came up then we
started rocking you know was it scary
whenever he got over to WWE did you feel
a little bit of like holy [__] how's
this gonna go because that's
a lot of ego you know it's all there's
at that point there's a lot of ego there
can only be so many men on the top of
the you know on the mountain tops well
it's it's kind of like you know it's
hard to explain but I play the dumb Fox
a lot you know and for me I'm always
looking who's got the big dollar sign on
their chest yeah and I don't mean to be
an ego Maniac but I mean I could
actually wrestle anybody at that time
and sell out I mean we sold out
everywhere constantly for years yeah it
didn't matter if I wrestled flare or
Kamala or Paul horned off Mr Wonderful
or it didn't matter you could wrestle
[__] hunt or buy it and dude I'd come
yeah
but yeah it was uh
it was it wasn't that with me it was
I wanted him to get over so I would have
somebody to work with and chase you know
so that was me it was about for me it
was like the old school thing the money
and the miles you know
so you know I wasn't really um that into
being on the road or getting beat on
every night yeah but there was so much
paper involved bro I was in yeah but I I
didn't take Tylenols Advil or leave for
for months now and I haven't
drank since January 1st but when I go
nice congrats when I go the other way
you're not swear it gets ugly are you
going in huh oh yeah well flare look I
mean yeah flare definitely I mean he can
say whatever he wants about me but I put
his ass to bed every time yeah
because he's not a clock vote come on
nine o'clock
yeah he's down last night he invites us
out right so we get out of work we had a
show last night we get out we uh text
his uh the lady is his assistant or
whatever she's like oh he just got now
who's the new victim her name's Gia
she's yeah I mean I'll tell you this
she's uh
she lifts chest a lot I'll tell you that
oh yeah I'll say that typical player I
love it she skips she skips arm and leg
day but she really
yeah uh and she said oh it's not he just
went to bed you know I just put him to
sleep but he lives that thing he usually
sneaks off on you though really I can
see it you'll be drinking at the bar
drinking the barn you'll think he's
going to the bathroom he don't come back
yeah and there's usually this huge tab
that he leaves so he's got a down
brother
believe me I know yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah a short story floor story yeah
yeah
in between back surgery number four or
five or six whatever it was I booked
this Hulk Mania tour first time I've
ever booked a tour on my own overseas
right Australia
so a higher Flair and hire a bunch of
wrestlers to come with me players I need
my money up front
okay Rick sure hi for one of his wives I
bet he brought one of them with him yeah
actually divorced her right he's always
got a wife on him somewhere yeah and so
I paid him up front and uh all of a
sudden we're getting ready to go to
Australia oh my back you know goes out
again and now the tour is booked I'm
following Britney Spears around I'm a
day behind her tour picking up leftovers
yeah
I thought and uh so my background had
another back surgery right before I left
and I had stitches in my back when I
went over there you know still that's
how crazy I used to be you know you need
yeah we traveled in bed about six months
okay I was gone let's go Wednesday we're
out of here yeah thank you yeah so we
get over there and the greatest thing
was the first night in Sydney Sydney
Australia Britney Spears get mad and
shot the crowd of bird right so nobody
came to our tours right the rest of the
tour so we bounced around and picked
everybody up you know
and I wrestled flare a bunch over there
and every 90 economy goes hey I need
another five grand tonight
what I already paid you oh no I need
another five grand
said okay here's five grand and then he
kept doing I said Rick why am I giving
you five grand well you know we're
drawing such big crowds you know you you
know you need to pay me another five
grand so depending another five grand I
went down to the bar he's buying drinks
for everybody I mean paying for
everything that's what he's doing with
the five grand he's keeping everybody in
the bar to party with him all night you
know and he wasn't going to bed at nine
o'clock back then he doesn't like to be
alone he said he said there's been times
in his life where he didn't he couldn't
absolutely couldn't stand to be alone
yeah I thought it was interesting yeah
because some people they like their
piece they like their their space
um yeah he just it was interesting even
talking to him he just is who he it
seems like there's
there's not a lot of getting he's just
the Nature Boy that's what he is bro
that's who he is it's very admirable and
it's interesting you know but I mean
that is who he is he likes to have a
good time and he will find it no matter
what and he wants you to have a good
time too
I don't think I could be Hulk Hogan 24
hours a day yeah I don't think I could I
wouldn't make it hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one
or this one